SPEAKER 1: Our speaker
tonight is Lee Habeeb.
Mr. Habeeb is vice president
of content at Sales
Media Group, which syndicates
national talk shows hosted
by Hugh Hewitt, Dennis
Prager, Larry Elder, Sebastian
Gorka, Mike Gallagher,
and Eric Metaxas.
A University of Virginia
School of Law graduate,
Mr. Habeeb is the founder
of American Private Radio
and host of its storytelling
show Our American Stories,
a weekday radio show syndicated
across the United States.
He is a weekly
columnist for Newsweek,
and he has written for
numerous other publications,
including National Review,
The Federalist, and LifeZette.
He is speaking this evening
about understanding America
through its stories.
Please join me in
welcoming Lee Habeeb.
[APPLAUSE]
LEE HABEEB: Thank you so much.
And before I start on
the formal presentation,
just a story because
the power of story
is what we're going to really
be talking about today.
I have a daughter, who
in the seventh grade--
was about to go into
the eighth grade.
And she had a boyfriend.
The boyfriend was somebody she
went to get ice cream with.
That was it-- with
adult supervision--
and he was going
into high school.
And so one day--
it was Saturday.
And it was the day she
would go to get ice cream.
And I would sit in the corner.
And she said, dad, I don't feel
like getting ice cream today.
Why don't we go to the movies?
And I'm thinking, hm,
what's going on, sweetheart?
She goes, I'm not going out
with my boyfriend anymore.
I said, why not?
She goes, I broke up with him.
I said, well, why did
you break up with him?
She goes, well, he's
going to high school.
And he's going to go
there, and he's just
going to break up with me,
so I broke up with him first.
[LAUGHTER]
So this is a preemptive breakup.
And so I thought-- and I did
this in front of my wife.
And every once in a while when
I'm telling stories in front
of my wife, my wife says this--
husbands here can attest--
what are you thinking?
But I shared some of
my life experience.
I said, you know,
sweetheart, when
I was a junior my
girlfriend was a senior.
And she was going
off to Rutgers.
And I was really afraid.
And so I preemptively
broke up with her.
One Saturday night I
said to my dad, dad,
let's go to the movies.
And my father said,
what's up, son?
And we had the
identical conversation.
Only when I told my
dad I had preemptively
broken up with my girlfriend,
he said, you're such a loser.
I'm not going out to
the movies with you.
[LAUGHTER]
So now I felt terrible,
so I called up
[? Donna ?] [INAUDIBLE].
I remember it like
it's yesterday.
I was crying.
I said, [? Donna, ?]
I'm so sorry.
I love you.
I was just so afraid you were
going to go off to college
and break up with me.
Would you take me back?
And she did.
And so my little girl said,
what happened next, dad?
I said, well, she went
to Rutgers and dumped me.
[LAUGHTER]
Not sure why I told you that
story, but figured I'd share.
So to start any talk
on storytelling,
it's best to start with Plato.
Those who tell the stories
rule society, he said.
He was right then,
and he's right now.
We know that the most
important book ever written
in world history and the
biggest blockbuster of all time,
the Bible, is nothing but
an endless series of stories
and some pretty damn good ones--
Adam and Eve, Cain and
Abel, the prodigal son.
And some people
think the OJ trial
may have been the
trial of the century,
but the trial of Jesus
Christ before the Sanhedrin
may have been the most
important in world history.
The fact is, the four
gospels and their parables
transformed history
and changed the world.
Indeed, that's what's so
powerful about the Bible
when you think about it.
Human beings across the
globe have for centuries
been stepping into those stories
and seeing ourselves in them.
For me, it was
the story of Jonah
that had the most
meaning in my life.
We all have at
least one story we
can point to in the Bible
that draws us closer to God
and to each other.
Stories shape reality
in human beings,
explained the great Brooklyn
novelist Paul Auster.
And the poet Muriel Rukeyser
famously said these words.
"The world is made up
of stories, not atoms."
If they are all
correct, why don't we,
who care about our
nation's story,
take the business of
storytelling more seriously?
It's odd, because
we take the business
of every other business
in American life
seriously except the
most important one.
The left has invested
vast fortunes
in storytelling
pipelines and fill them
with stories that
shape what Americans
think about everything--
business, family, government,
capitalism, our history,
even God.
To understand how
we let this happen,
we must first understand
why we let it happen.
First, we really don't
think storytelling matters.
How do I know?
How many of us would be
happy if a child of ours
told us they wanted to
be an actor or a writer?
Now if that same child told us
they wanted to join the Marine
Corps, I know how we'd react.
We'd be proud.
At NYU's Tisch School of
the Arts a few years ago,
Robert De Niro gave the
commencement speech.
He told a few jokes about his
craft, and then he got serious.
He implored the graduates to
work hard and be fearless.
He reminded them
that they're part
of an important
tribe called artists
and that their work
matters and shapes
the life of their country.
De Niro spoke to them like
they were new Army recruits.
That's because the left views
careers in the arts the way
we view careers in the
military and business.
They believe in this stuff.
We don't.
Here's the second reason
we failed up till now.
Rather than invest
in storytelling,
we've spent billions of
dollars on think tanks
over the past few decades,
on public policy research.
Those PhDs and their work
serve a vital role, no doubt,
but do we believe
white papers and op
eds can change the country,
that facts, debate,
and our superior
arguments alone can change
the narrative of a country?
When we do spend
money on media, we
pour billions into political
ads every election cycle.
What do we have to show for it?
[LAUGHTER]
Like I said, what do we--
it's actually tragic.
Because if you think
about this, the people who
are getting these
advertising dollars,
Comcast, Disney,
are the very people
who use our advertising dollars
to funnel Jimmy Kimmel Show
and pay for all the
entertainment that attacks us.
We're actually funding
our enemy's platforms.
No disrespect, but asking
PhDs and politicians
to change the culture is
like asking an NFL linebacker
like Clay Matthews
to be a ballerina.
[LAUGHTER]
Rather than do what we naturally
do in any other business, which
is compete, we have chosen
an interesting alternative
and an unattractive
one, whining.
And by the way,
we whine endlessly
about Hollywood media bias.
And to be fair, we have
a lot to whine about.
When's the last time
you saw a businessman
cast as the good guy and a
bureaucrat as the bad guy
on a TV show, or a good guy
priest and a bad guy union
boss in a movie?
A long time ago, actually.
It was Rod Steiger playing
the corrupt union boss
and Karl Malden the heroic
priest in Elia Kazan's 1954
masterpiece On the Waterfront.
Remember the scene
where the dock worker
is killed by union
goons for testifying
against their bosses?
And there's Father Barry in that
boat calling out the bad guys.
One thug threw a can
at the Father's head.
Another yelled, "Go back
to your church, Father."
He yells back,
"This is my church."
It made our hair stand up
on our heads, our bodies.
It was so beautiful.
So why do stories move people in
ways facts and arguments can't?
It's simple.
Human beings are hard wired
to absorb the narrative form.
Stories have structure,
characters, plot, themes,
and emotion, all of
which reflect life.
Stories change hearts.
They change minds.
They change everything.
That's why it is
easy for me to assert
that storytelling is the world's
oldest and best killer app.
And stories live in the
hearts and minds of people
long after they're told.
Take Arthur Miller's
plays, which revolve mostly
around father-son
relationships, but always
there's that scene that
hammers capitalism,
like the one in Death of a
Salesman where Willy Loman begs
for his job while his boss plays
with a machine on his desk.
Miller wrote that play in 1949.
He died in 2006.
People are still
moved by that story.
The power that media
ownership confers
to the left on the
storytelling front is profound.
And the biggest
advantage is this--
they choose the
stories that get told.
But much more
important, they choose
the stories that don't get told.
That curation power
affects outcomes.
If artists want
their stories chosen,
they'd best comport with the
curators' worldview, which
drives artists to censor
themselves without even knowing
it because they need the work.
That's why so many
artists are liberal.
Their bosses are.
Another power of media ownership
is its asymmetric nature.
A handful of owners
make the majority of us
feel as if we're minorities
in our own country.
It's why dictators
always seize the media,
because what they're seizing
is their nation's story.
Sadly, the left just did
that, but not by force.
We just kind of let them.
Back in 2004, the
author Louisa Lim
visited four Beijing
universities.
What would happen, he wondered,
when he showed students
a photo of tank man?
Would they recognize it?
You know the iconic picture,
the lone man, two shopping bags
in hand, standing in front of
a line of tanks in defiance
of the crackdown by
the Chinese government
at Tiananmen Square in 1989.
It turned out that only
15% of the Beijing students
recognized the picture.
That wasn't an accident.
As Lim explained in his book The
People's Republic of Amnesia--
Tiananmen Revisited,
the Chinese authorities
were determined to blot out
public memory of the protests.
George Orwell knew why.
He said this--
"The most effective
way to destroy a people
is to obliterate
their understanding
of their own history."
In America, we have
a different problem.
Many on the left who don't
care for America, capitalism,
or the Constitution
work hard to promote
the most shameful
aspects of our story
while erasing from public memory
our most positive aspects.
It's China in reverse, and a
very different kind of amnesia
is setting in.
We Conservatives own a
few media platforms--
Fox News, talk
radio, some websites.
But it's mostly
news and opinion.
It's programming designed
to feed the choir
and to preach to the
choir, not grow it.
We've invested little in
storytelling platforms
that will attract new fans
to this great brand called
America.
And we're the business people?
We're the smart guys?
In spoken word formats,
the storytelling elephant
in the room is NPR.
They have 30 million people
listening and $350 million
in annual revenue with only
10% coming from the government.
NPR also dominates
the podcast world,
with five of the top 10
podcasts in the country.
Several years ago, with the
help of some national donors
and Hillsdale College,
a team of storytellers
got together to launch
a non-profit alternative
to NPR and a daily two-hour
syndicated storytelling show,
one that celebrates America
and the events and people who
made the country great.
From the arts to sports
and business to history,
Our American
Stories was designed
to tell the story of
America to Americans.
Many of the stories
revolve around
character, resilience, and
the power and persistence
of imagination.
This is a story
about an improbable
story about an author
of America's songbook.
Few people write as many hits.
Fewer still write
as many standards.
songs that become
part of our national identity.
"White Christmas" and
"God Bless America,"
both of which this
one man wrote,
are a part of our cultural DNA.
He did it without
formal training.
He couldn't read or write music
and played almost entirely
in the key of F-sharp
because it was easier
for his untrained
fingers to play
the elevated,
well-spaced black keys.
He said this-- "The black keys
are right under your fingers.
The key of C is for
people who study music."
Irving Berlin's story
is about many things--
hard work, adversity,
creativity,
about America itself.
He was born Israel
Beilin in Russia
in 1888, one of eight
children and son
to a cantor in the
local synagogue.
His family fled Russia after
their village was destroyed
in an anti-Semitic pogrom.
Berlin's only memory was
of his father, quote,
"lying in a blanket
by the side of a road,
watching his house
burn to the ground."
His family settled in New York.
But there would be more tragedy
to come in young Irving's life.
None was worse than the loss of
his father when he was eight.
It was at a job waiting tables
to support his family that he
discovered a particular talent.
His tips skyrocketed when
he hummed songs of the day.
Singing at tables soon turned
into a lifetime of songwriting.
In 1911, his "Alexander's
Ragtime Band"
climbed to number two
on the billboard charts.
But ragtime wasn't his thing.
He wanted to create
his own version
of American music,
something romantic that
appealed to the masses.
He did just that.
He wrote over 1,500 songs.
He told his biographer he
didn't believe in inspiration
and that his most
successful compositions
were the result of hard work.
One of his successes
started as a failure.
Berlin wrote "God Bless
America" originally in 1918
while serving in the army,
but he couldn't find a buyer.
In 1938, as Hitler
was rising to power,
Berlin pulled that
song out of his drawer,
Kate Smith recorded it,
and the rest was history.
Berlin's daughter
wrote that her father
meant every word of that song.
Quote, "It was
the land he loved.
It was his home sweet home.
He, the immigrant who
made good, was saying
thank you to his country."
Writing one anthem would
be enough for any mortal,
but in 1941, Berlin wrote
another, "White Christmas,"
which would sell 50 million
copies for Bing Crosby
and become the best-selling
single of all time
and one of the world's most
beloved Christmas songs.
Those two anthems may be
the most compelling aspect
of Berlin's legacy.
A Jew wrote "White Christmas."
And a Russian wrote
"God Bless America."
And he was the same damn guy.
Only in America is such
a thing possible, folks.
Only in America is Irving
Berlin's life possible.
He died at the age
of 101 a wealthy man,
in large part because he owned
his own publishing catalog.
America's artists,
Berlin included,
owe a debt of gratitude
to our nation's founders,
who secured not just
property rights,
but intellectual property,
too, and the freedom
to write about anything
without recourse
from their own government.
It is why American artists
are the most prolific
in the world, because they
are the freest in the world
and live in a place where
their ideas are protected, too,
and by our nation's Founder
and the Constitution itself,
Article I.
The next story is
about that Founder,
because it wasn't any Founder
who wanted to protect ideas.
He was a Founder who worked
hard to protect ideas
through something called a
patent because he was himself
an inventor, a writer,
and a publisher.
Benjamin Franklin understood
the power of ideas.
More importantly, he
understood the value of ideas.
He became a very rich man
from Poor Richard's Almanac.
The story reflects
a deep division--
the one I'm about to tell you--
within our
not-yet-formed country,
a division that split not
just fellow countrymen,
but families, too.
And the consequences
for choosing a side
in this division was not simply
a tweet storm or a Facebook
post.
Quote, "An awful silence
pervaded the house
as we were called
up one after another
to the table of the president of
Congress," Benjamin Rush said,
"to sign what was believed
by many at the time
to be our own death warrant."
Rush was right.
The British government
considered the Declaration
of Independence a
treasonous document,
and treason was a capital crime.
How divided was America?
One look at Benjamin Franklin's
family tells the story.
The printer, inventor,
writer, and diplomat
was a driving force of the
American Enlightenment,
but his own home was torn
apart by our first civil war.
Franklin's son William
was illegitimate,
but he had all the
advantages that any other boy
in this world could want.
Throughout their lives, father
and son were extremely close.
Franklin even used his
influence to secure
his son the royal
governorship of New Jersey.
Neither man could
have imagined they'd
one day be forced to choose
between king and country.
The father joined the
cause of the Patriots late
and urged his son to join him.
William insisted that
dad join the Loyalists.
That choice led to the son's
arrest and a two-year stint
in the worst prison in
America, the Litchfield
Gaol in Connecticut.
Quote, "It was a
destination of last resort
for outlaws condemned
to be hanged,
convicted murderers,
reprobates, and traitors,"
wrote historian David Epstein.
After his release from prison,
William emigrated to England,
never to return home.
A few years before his
death, Ben Franklin
received a letter from
his son, who was hoping
for a chance at reconciliation.
The father wrote back
promptly-- and imagine
getting this kind of a
letter from your dad-- quote,
"Nothing has hurt
me so much, son,
and affected me with
such keen sensation
as to find myself deserted
in my old age by my only son,
and not only deserted,
but to find him taking up
arms against me in a cause
wherein my good fame, fortune,
and life were all at stake."
That was it.
The two men would
never reconcile.
Franklin died a wealthy man.
He left his son nothing.
The political divide
today is still
about power in a distant
city, but that distant city
isn't London.
It's Washington, DC.
It's a fight we've been having
since our founding, fights
about power, fights
about sovereignty.
That last story was situated
in the 18th century.
This next is about one of
America's great 20th-century
leaders, Martin Luther King.
His Christian faith was an
animating force in his life,
as was the book he dedicated
his life's study to, the Bible.
Bill Maher, the comedian,
once described the Bible
as a book most Christians
don't actually read.
He said this--
"It's like a software license.
Christians scroll down to the
bottom and click I Agree."
Martin Luther King
thought differently.
The Bible wasn't a
software license.
It was software code,
a deep mysterious code
authored by a God for
man's eternal purposes.
Indeed, he found the Bible so
compelling, King, so relevant
in the 20th century, that his
undergraduate degree and PhD
were both in Bible studies.
Leaving God out of Martin
Luther King's life story,
and the Bible, is like leaving
automobiles out of Henry
Ford's life or hamburgers
out of Ray Kroc's.
But that's precisely
what the media
does at every turn every year
when they celebrate his life.
Take the last night
of King's life.
As he headed into Memphis in
1968, he knew he was in danger.
Quote, "There's no way
you can keep somebody
from killing you,"
he told reporters,
"if they really
want to kill you."
Bomb threats delayed his
flight into Memphis that night.
And though King was troubled,
he told supporters, quote,
"I'd rather be
dead than afraid."
Then came his speech
at the Mason Temple
the night of April 3.
It was as if the 39-year-old
knew his life would soon end.
A major theme of
that speech was fear.
And by the way, is it not
a major theme of the Bible?
The other was the story
"the Good Samaritan,"
a parable told by Jesus
in the Gospel of Luke.
King told the audience about a
trip he and his wife made along
the Jericho Road and why
he thought two men passed
a stranger in need
and why one didn't.
Quote, and this is from
the sermon directly,
"It's a winding,
meandering, dangerous road,
conducive to ambushing,"
he told the audience.
"And you know, it's possible
that the priest and the Levite
looked over at that
man on the ground
and wondered if the
robbers were still around.
Or it's possible they
felt the man on the ground
was acting like he'd been robbed
and hurt in order to lure them
there for easy seizure.
And so the first
question the Levite
asked was, as I stop
to help this man, what
will happen to me?
Then the Good Samaritan came by,
and he reversed the question.
If I don't stop to help this
man, what will happen to him?
That's the question before
you tonight," King preached.
A few minutes later,
the speech, which
had by now turned into a sermon,
started its prophetic turn.
"Like anybody," he said, "I'd
like to live a long life.
Longevity has its place.
But I'm not concerned
about that now.
I just want to do
God's will," King
told the spellbound audience.
"He's allowed me to go
up to the mountaintop,
and I've looked over it.
And I've seen the promised land.
And I may not get
there with you,
but I want you to know tonight
that as we a people will,
in the end, finally, we will
get to the promised land."
On the eve of April 4, not
long before he was gunned down
at the Lorraine
Hotel in Memphis,
King's last words
were to a musician
named Ben Branch,
who was scheduled
to perform at an event
later on that night.
"Ben," he said, "make sure
you play 'Take My Hand,
Precious Lord.'
Play it real slow.
Play it pretty."
The enduring truth
of this story,
one the media cannot
rewrite, is this--
Martin Luther King's desire
to serve the God he loved
changed forever the
country he loved.
This last story that
I'm about to tell you
is the story of a
city and a disaster,
the Great Chicago Fire of 1871,
and the even more remarkable
story of the great
Chicago recovery.
Experts disagree on
how that fire started.
Some say it was a cow.
Others say it was vandals.
But everyone agrees on
why the fire started.
It was Chicago's
remarkable growth.
In 1840, the city had
a mere 4,500 residents.
10 years later, it
passed the 30,000 mark.
By 1860, it had grown to
100,000, and by 1870, 300,000.
What led to all that growth?
As the saying goes,
location, location, location.
Chicago was near the
center of the country,
near where the waterways
and railways met.
It was a perfect place
for anything and anyone
to get anywhere.
Timing also played a part.
America was going
through a transformation
from a rural power to
an industrial power.
But how did all of that
growth, all of that life,
lead to a near-death experience?
As a Chicago
historian explained,
Chicago had to build quickly, so
they built it all out of wood.
It was quick and easy and cheap.
Mother nature played
her part, too.
Meteorologist Tom Skilling said,
quote, "It was an exceedingly
dry summer and fall.
Worse still, winter
was approaching,
and those wood houses were
filled with firewood."
The Chicago Fire, it turns
out, wasn't just predictable.
It was inevitable.
It started out on the west
side and quickly roared out
of control, a steady
wind propelling
the inferno from block to block
and even across the Chicago
River.
30 hours later, the fire
finally ran out of fuel
because there was
nothing left to burn.
The fire claimed nearly 300
lives, a third of the city
lay in ruins, and 100,000
people were homeless.
Most of the hotels, stores,
and banks were destroyed.
By the way, that's State Street.
A picture in a second will
show you that same shot,
same angle, 20 years later.
What happened next
revealed the character
of the city and the nation.
There was no FEMA back then, no
Illinois Emergency Management,
no one to blame, no one to sue,
and no appetite for victimhood.
Even before the bricks
stopped smoking,
the city's leaders were
planning a comeback.
The Reverend Robert Collier told
his congregation these words.
"We have not lost our geography.
Nature called the lakes, the
forests, and the prairies
together in convention
long before we were born.
And they have decided
that on this spot
a great city would be rebuilt."
Within 48 hours, 12 of the
29 banks that burned down
were operating in
makeshift facilities
to get money to customers.
Bankers got busy
raising capital.
One sent letters to
bankers all over the globe
urging them to
invest and loan money
to the great people of Chicago.
Chicago was rebuilt at
an unimaginable pace.
By 1880, its population
reached 500,000.
And by 1890, it
passed the 1 million
mark, becoming the second
biggest city in America.
Same street.
Same camera angle.
The people of
Chicago did all of it
without the help of the
state or federal government.
American optimism, resilience,
character, and capitalism
itself rebuilt the city.
Folks, we must start telling the
story of America to Americans,
stories about all that's
good and decent and beautiful
about this country.
We must address matters
of the heart, too.
Not talking about
love is where we all
go wrong, because it's
love that builds a city.
We must tell stories
about faith, too,
and the beautiful things
we do because of our faith.
America is unimaginable
without it,
because the battle
lines in America
are not just between
left and right.
In the end, they're
between up versus down.
And that is the material world
versus the spiritual world.
Folks, to continue
to let the left alone
tell the story of America
isn't just gross negligence,
it's cultural suicide.
We have great stories to tell.
Let's start telling them.
How hard can it be?
After all, liberals do it.
That's all, folks.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: We have time
for some questions,
and there are microphones.
Lee, do you want to [INAUDIBLE]?
LEE HABEEB: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
It's a wonderful thing
that you're doing.
LEE HABEEB: I appreciate it.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: But let me
tell you, as a writer,
what the difficulties are.
Editors, publishers, are looking
for a certain point of view.
And it's hard to even get
through the front door.
And I was a nationally
syndicated columnist
in 122 papers.
The generation of
today-- course,
I was a different generation--
doesn't want to talk to me
because of my point of view.
The grants that you try to go
for as far as the internships,
the money that even
the government gives,
has a different point of view.
And the newspapers
are owned, the media--
why aren't we buying?
Why aren't we buying them?
Why aren't we spending
money in order
to create our own market as far
as storytelling is concerned?
So those are just
some of the things
that I would like you to address
if you have any ideas on it.
LEE HABEEB: I'd be happy to.
And I think you're--
Laura Ingraham and I--
I went to law school
with Laura Ingraham
and started her national show.
In 1996, we got hired by
MSNBC, believe it or not,
to do a TV show on MSNBC, back
when nobody was watching it
and they pretended
not to be liberal.
Only I was stuck in
Secaucus, New Jersey all day,
and it was miserable, and
everybody was liberal.
But there was this
show in the morning
called The [INAUDIBLE] Show.
And Laura and I learned
a lot about radio,
and we got into radio.
But in 1996, [? 15-year ?]
[? hurt ?] had [? started. ?]
CNN [? had it. ?] A guy named
Roger Ailes got together with
a billionaire named
Rupert Murdoch,
and they decided to slide a
lot of money up to the table
and say, let's compete.
And they competed.
And Fox News won.
And I've seen it
happen again and again.
Let's take a film director that
I think we all know and love,
Clint Eastwood.
Since 1991, Clint Eastwood
has done 22 or 23 movies,
I'm not sure of which.
Eight have been number
one or number two
and over a billion
dollars in the box office.
He has total creative
control of his movies.
And well, why not?
They make money.
I think we're getting
to a place now
where a lot of our
donors and investors
who've spent a lot of
money on political ads
and a lot of money
in other places
are now starting to think
hard about storytelling.
And the good news is
that the barrier to entry
are much lower than
they used to be,
much lower than they used to be.
And there's just
tremendous demand, I mean,
that every Clint Eastwood movie
is number one or number two.
Think about The Unforgiven.
Think about Gran Torino.
I mean, there was a movie
with a Catholic priest who
was trying to do good,
trying to influence
the old cranky bastard, right?
And you would have thought
he was incorrigible,
except what does he do?
These total strangers
who he didn't
like, who he insulted routinely,
he ended up loving, willing
his perfect,
perfect car to them,
and in an act of
self-sacrifice gets
himself shot to free that
family from thugs and gangsters.
It was a beautiful movie.
And Americans were
craving for it.
And our capitalists just have to
start stepping up to the plate
and putting the money up.
And that's why we're
doing what we're
doing, because one success
can beget more successes.
Moreover, and I'll
leave you with this,
one of the things that's
missing is executive talent.
There are two publicly
traded companies in America
that are run by conservatives,
Fox News and Salem Media Group.
And I'm the VP of content
at Salem Media Group.
If and when I decide
to leave that position,
a very nice paying position,
that position will be filled.
And guess how many other
jobs are out there for me
immediately?
None.
I leave this thing
and I'm a liberal
and I got to start my own
thing, there's 25 other jobs
if I decide to drop back in.
So I think these are things
we know we have to address,
and we're about to
start addressing them.
I got so tired of complaining
and whining about it
that I went ahead and
talked to some capitalists
and they liked the idea, gave us
some money, and said, go at it.
So I think this is more about
us not complaining anymore, not
whining about our circumstance.
I mean, goodness, Washington
looked out into Brooklyn Harbor
and saw an armada coming in--
slightly more difficult
problem, right?
So I just think that--
you know, the word Stockholm
syndrome always interested me,
because, you know, my wife
had been sexually abused
for six years.
And I said to her, well, how--
why didn't you leave?
And she said, you just don't.
You start to identify
with the captor.
The captor gets in your head,
and pretty soon you're stuck.
And the real power
of the media is
that we're all in a sort of
Stockholm syndrome-like effect.
We keep seeing the
media coming at us,
and we think it's hopeless.
Meanwhile, we keep
winning elections.
We heard that Barack Obama had
Google, and he had Facebook,
and that the ascendancy of
the digital social revolution
would lead to a
Democratic hegemony,
and the Tea Party came
in and swept the day.
[INAUDIBLE] had nobody
rooting for him.
And there was just
NBC, ABC, and CBS.
They were all
rooting against him.
There was no Fox News.
There was no Drudge.
There was nothing.
He won 49 states
in his second race.
So the American people
just need to be fed.
And I think we're trying
to prove that authority
with our proposition.
But I know the problem.
Look, I experienced
it a good deal
of my life in the 1990s
when Laura and I were
trying to start.
There was no talk radio.
I mean, there was maybe one talk
station in every fifth market.
And it wasn't until 2001 when
we got nationally syndicated,
Hannity got syndicated.
[? Matt ?] got syndicated.
And suddenly, there
was a lot of content.
And so suddenly there were
a lot of talk stations
to [? park ?] that content.
And by the way, you want to talk
about a conservative dialogue--
there's 45 million people
listening to conservative talk
radio.
And it has made all the
difference in the world.
We have come to dominate
talk radio in a way
that no liberal, no leftist
could have imagined.
I remember, and I'm sure all
you do, the first time you heard
that cry of Rush Limbaugh.
You went, that's me.
Finally, finally someone's
talking to me in my language.
So if we make movies that
people want, they'll come.
I have no question if we
build it, they'll come.
Next question.
AUDIENCE: What's your
greatest source of hope?
LEE HABEEB: God.
You know, Malcolm Gladwell
was on Laura's show.
And she's always asking
me for questions,
because we love to get
the authors comfortable,
and then we ask them a zinger.
And well, we had a zinger for
Malcolm, because, of course,
when he was writing his book
about David and Goliath,
he told a really great story.
And he talked about
how David had prepared
for years with those
five smooth stones
and how Goliath was his
stumbling adversary,
and that David had
all the advantages
and Goliath didn't, because the
new game was about speed, not
about size.
You think David
knew any of that?
You think David got there and
won that battle just because
of all that preparation?
So she let Malcolm
opine and opine,
but Malcolm had left one
thing out of his book.
David had God on his side.
And he knew it.
This helps.
So God gives me hope.
And going on campuses
actually gives me hope.
I live in Oxford, Mississippi.
That's where we do our show.
And I see young people battling
back in their own ways,
often just through--
just a one of these to
the campus protesters.
And I think sometimes we
give the campus protesters
a little too much credit.
I don't like what's
happening in our campuses.
But our young people are smart.
I found Ronald Reagan.
I got you.
That was my first vote.
Everybody told me, oh, young
people won't vote for Regan.
They won't vote for him.
He's old.
They won't-- but
what were we told?
He was going to push
[INAUDIBLE] off the cliff.
He was going to get
us into a nuclear war.
He was an actor.
He was an idiot.
He was lazy.
I mean, the prevailing
theme about Reagan
was that he was going to lose
and that, you know, nobody
was going to vote for him.
Meanwhile, I voted for him.
Laura Ingraham voted for him.
[INAUDIBLE]---- every young
person I know voted for him,
because Jimmy Carter was
saying the following.
America's best
days are behind us.
Put on a sweater and
love your thermostat.
And I thought, that sucks.
That sucks.
I'm going with the old guy who
says our best days are ahead.
And by the way, let me tell
you about the old days,
because we're a great country.
We're a great people.
And so I think half
of our problem is us.
We walk around
acting as if we're
losing when we're winning.
And we act like we have no hope.
And this is what the left
does and their media control
does best of all.
Look, if you believe
that there's a God
and there's a Satan, Satan
wants to steal your joy
and make you angry.
So when we're angry, we're
working on behalf of the left.
When we're loving and
we're reaching out
and we're telling
stories and we're
reaching out to our
neighbors, there's a delight.
Once a year-- I'll tell you
a quick story-- once a year,
there's this Lebanese professor
at Ole Miss who invites me in,
so I get to speak to 500 kids.
The faculty goes crazy.
He doesn't care.
He's tenured.
He's a Christian and
he's a conservative.
He goes, Habeeb, do what you do.
So I get 500 kids in a room.
And I see something
very interesting.
I tell everybody to
close their eyes.
I say, how many of you believe
in the thing called love,
even though it's not provable,
even though no scientists can
measure it?
How many of you believe
in a thing called love?
Every single hand goes up.
And by the way, I don't have
them look, and I filmed it.
And so now I say,
keep your eyes closed.
How many of you, if you met
the proper person in your life,
and it was your soulmate
or someone you really
thought you could spend
the rest of your life with,
how many of you would
want to get married?
Almost all the hands stayed up.
Be still my heart.
Almost total agreement.
All these kids from
different walks
of life, all different
ideas [INAUDIBLE]..
And then I keep going.
How many of you want
to have children
if you found that dream person?
Almost all the hands stayed up.
Now, maybe they'd want
to have them later.
That's beside the point.
So I keep their heads down
and their eyes closed.
I said, now, how many of
you, if you had two children,
one did their homework,
one did all their work,
one was dutiful, and
then you had another
who didn't do anything, stayed
in the room, played loud music,
and just played video games
and didn't do any chores,
how many of you would give
them the same allowance?
Not a single hand went up.
So then I said,
raise your heads.
I said, let's play the video.
Who said we don't agree
on a lot of things?
And then I asked some questions.
Did you create inequality by
giving one kid an allowance
and one getting nothing?
And is it a bad thing
or a good thing?
And I asked just a
few more questions,
and [INAUDIBLE]
they had a line of,
like, 300 kids going,
[? did you ?] teach you?
And I didn't give
them an answer.
I just asked them a
bunch of questions.
And Chris [INAUDIBLE] and I--
Chris is on the board of
[? APR, ?] was telling me
a story about watching
Milton Friedman back
when he was at the
University of Michigan,
and watching Milton
Friedman on, of all places,
the Phil Donahue show.
Google it.
Put out Phil Donahue
and Milton Friedman.
All Phil Donahue
is doing is asking
questions in a proper series.
And Phil Donahue is,
like, gesticulating.
By the time, five or
six minutes passes,
Phil Donahue doesn't know what
to do with himself, because he
can't answer a series of
very simple questions.
So I have tremendous hope,
not only for the country--
we've got God on our side.
We've got the
Constitution on our side.
We've got an amazing people.
And I got to tell you this.
We have immigration on our side.
We retold one story
about a Chinese-American
who did a thought experiment.
He was wondering
how many Americans
try to become Chinese citizens.
So he said, what the heck?
Let me see what
that would be like.
So he goes through the process.
And when he's going
through the process,
he discovers that not a
single American that year
had tried to become
a Chinese citizen.
So then he calls
some pals that he
had because he had gone to
some overseas fancy school,
and it turns out they were doing
the thought experiment, too.
There wasn't a person
in Europe who'd
tried to become a
Chinese citizen.
And at the end of this little
sort of story that he told us,
he said, you know, I'm
so hopeful about America,
because we're great at
creating Chinese-Americans.
But China is really bad at
creating American-Chinese.
And this is true.
And so this is our advantage.
The world wants to come here.
And I love that the left
says we're a racist nation
and yet all these
dark-skinned immigrants
are trying to come here, like my
Lebanese and Sicilian parents.
So their claims are false.
They get us too angry.
If we were a little more
confident in our step,
a little more
confident in our walk,
we'd do what Reagan always did,
because remember what Reagan
did when they'd do what he did?
He would just go,
there you go again.
He laughed it off.
That's how confident
he was in his views.
He shrugged it off.
And how humiliating for your
opponent to just be laughed at.
So very hopeful.
Always hopeful.
I got God on my side.
Any other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You
mentioned the old days.
A lot of things that
we like about America
were there at the beginning, but
that's not where they started.
Is there ever a need
to not just tell
America's stories,
but the stories that
made America what it was?
LEE HABEEB: Yeah, and we do--
what we tend to do on our show
is a mixture of things.
So for every story we tell about
George Washington, which we'll
do, we'll tell a story about
some young Venezuelan immigrant
who left the oil
patch of Venezuela.
This particular gentleman
left when Hugo Chavez
consolidated the oil industry.
And why he left was
because the moment
he consolidated the oil
industry, Chavez's pals
all got the jobs and
the competent people
all left because, well,
you know what happens
when nepotism rules the day.
Incompetence wins.
Competence is punished.
So they said, what the heck?
Let's get out of here.
Let's go to the oil patch.
And with no money to their
name, he and his friends
worked hard, cleaned
fracking trucks,
bought a couple
fracking trucks, and now
run a multimillion-dollar
business.
And so connecting our
past to our present,
and why did that happen?
And he started talking
about property rights.
He started to talk
about capital.
He started talking about how
a contract meant something.
Now, these are things we
take for granted [INAUDIBLE]..
You know, we play this piece--
I think it's almost worth
playing if I can find it.
We do an hour on Justice
Scalia's life every year.
I mean, shame on us.
Has the left done nine
documentaries by now on RBG,
or 10?
I mean, there's a new
one comes out every day.
I walked out of Ole Miss,
of the one documentary
that they played there, because
I wanted to see the reaction,
to see what the professors did.
They had about 1,000
people at their law school
watch a documentary
about Ginsburg.
And as I walked out,
I'm just talking
to some of the students,
a lot of undergrads,
a lot of people
in the community,
and they were just so horrified
when I asked them, hey,
did you know that
Ruth Bader Ginsburg
wasn't the first female
Supreme Court Justice?
They didn't know that.
[INAUDIBLE] through
this documentary,
there was like one
little passage,
there was like one little
picture of Sandra Day O'Connor,
and that was it.
And we did a story about
Scalia in his own words.
And not just about the
Constitution, right?
I mean, he's spoken about so
many things in so many places.
And when people
hear Scalia talk,
it's just a remarkable thing.
The most powerful
thing, on the day
before he died, the
day after he died,
we asked people for their
favorite Scalia stories.
And this one gentleman who
writes for the Acton Institute
told this story
about how he would
go to church fairly
regularly on a weekday
afternoon in the same church
near the Court, Catholic
Church, that Scalia went to.
And one day, the church
was pretty empty.
He was standing in the back.
Scalia didn't notice him.
He didn't notice
Scalia at first,
but then he saw the justice.
And he saw a woman walk up
to the justice who looked,
as he had said, like
the kind of woman
you'd avoid on
the street-- sores
on her hands, open
sores, a homeless person,
a troubled person, he said.
He said, and I want Justice
Scalia put his arm around her.
I watched Justice
Scalia stroke her arm.
I watched him touch
her, whisper words
of reassurance and comfort to
her for about five minutes.
And then whatever he
said did reassure her.
It looked like he had
given her a few dollars,
again tapped her on the
back, rubbed her back,
and sent her on her way.
And then he went on his way.
And he said, and then I
saw a man, a beautiful man,
who was honoring his God and
doing it the way God commanded,
which is to love the stranger.
If we don't tell
stories about this,
not just the jurisprudence of
Scalia, but the man Scalia,
we're doing a
tremendous disservice.
And while they prop up Ginsburg
and we're silent with Scalia,
we're just--
we have ourselves to blame.
So those are the kind of
things we just love to do.
And we like to connect our
glorious past to the present.
I don't know if any of
you see the country music
special by Ken Burns, but I
urge all of you to see it.
It's absolutely remarkable.
And what you really feel as
you get closer to country--
and you can tell Burns
had just discovered
this thing called country music.
If you recall, his first
documentary on American music--
and he's done maybe 20
by now, but his first one
was on jazz, because
he's a city guy.
So he actually thought jazz was
America's music, only it never
was, because it never
caught on, because it
was too complex, too highbrow
for the average American.
No, country music and rock and
roll were the American music.
This is what America
latched onto.
This is what we have
exported to the world
and we're selling like crazy.
And what was interesting
about listening
to the country
musicians is they all
had a deep respect and reverence
for their predecessors.
They all knew every
Bill Monroe song.
Chet Atkins song.
And yet they also wanted
to take that country
music, their
predecessors' great art,
and move it to another place.
So both loving the formational
character and necessity of what
brought country to
country, and yet
how to make America our own.
So we want to love
George Washington,
but we want to say that
this is our country now.
How do we take the principles
of the Constitution,
the rule of law, and
apply it to our life?
How do we create our culture?
I don't think
Christians, particularly,
and conservatives
are good enough
in asserting our own
cultural identity.
We have simply had an
identity by reaction
to the adversary's identity.
And our identity has become
a reactionary identity.
And that's a shame, because
we have so much, so much,
so much to believe in
and an identity that's
so much richer than theirs.
Theirs is basically--
their stories
are built on lies, in the end.
And ours are built on truth.
And there was a last moment--
Wynton Marsalis is sitting there
talking about country music,
and Wynton--
believe it or not,
this is crazy,
but an African-American
jazz composer
and one of our best
musicians is one
of the regular people talking
through this eight-hour country
music special.
And he starts to talk
about Hank Williams.
And he talks about what
the songs are about.
He goes, listen to that
lonely [INAUDIBLE] the voice.
Listen to that pain.
Listen to that suffering.
My wife did me wrong.
My husband did me wrong.
I let my God down.
I didn't let my God down.
God, love, faith, fear.
We black people, we're always
singing about external stuff.
Why aren't we talking
about that, too?
We're all human beings.
This is Wynton Marsalis
condemning his own people,
his own music, for
being superficial,
for being external,
and for not talking
about our own personal
sins and failings,
which is what country
music does better
than any other musical
idiom known to man.
It's a confessional,
most great country music,
just a pure confessional.
Most black music is the
protest [INAUDIBLE],,
says nothing about the
person and their sins.
It says and questions
other people's sins,
which is what Wynton Marsalis
thought made it empty,
empty music.
Fascinating.
One last question?
Yes [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: So can you
[INAUDIBLE] tell us
what the vision of
Our American Stories
was for you, where
you're at today,
and you hope to be in
the next five years?
LEE HABEEB: Sure.
About five years ago, I
was on a conference call--
I accompanied Bill Bennett,
who of all the people
I've spent a lot
of time with, Bill
had the most impact
on both me and Laura.
Laura's first job
was for Bill Bennett
in the Reagan administration,
writing speeches for Bill.
And Bill just has a way of
mentoring people and demanding
that they read.
He wants us to read.
And it's always, did
you read that book?
Did you read that book?
And he makes you feel like--
I mean, even if you
read a lot of books,
he has this routine ability
to make you feel like a moron.
But it's good.
He doesn't do it
condescendingly.
He's challenging you all
the time to read more.
So he has this speech that
is a typical stump speech.
But on this particular
day, Bill's really grumpy.
So he's speaking to the
Florida 100, like, the movers
and shakers of Florida.
And he just goes off script.
And he gives a talk about
the American story and how
we're losing the narrative.
And I mean, it was just--
he was not happy.
By the way, the
audience was mesmerized.
But I'm sitting there,
and every once in a while,
he's looking at me.
Then the next day,
well, we have what
we call our Salem
editorial meetings, which
is when all the hosts and
some outside writers join,
Bill's at it again.
Are we moving the
needle, he kept
asking us, especially some of
his senior producers and vice
presidents.
Are we changing anybody?
We do an interview-- what
he was really saying was,
are we bringing new
people to the choir?
Are we growing market share?
And I think he knew the answer.
We weren't.
And in some ways, it was
just about at that time
when the chorus, the
conservative chorus,
was starting to pick at itself.
So we weren't just
growing the choir.
We're actually sort of dividing
and splitting up the choir.
RINOs, Tea Party, I mean, it
was just getting to that point
where we were all just--
we were killing each other.
And so I took it personally.
I really listened to him.
And so the next
day I just thought,
Bill, what's that all about?
And he said, you
know, what would
This American Life, the NPR
product, which he loved,
he said, what would
This American Life
sound like if the people
making it liked their country?
It was a damn good question.
And that just,
that was it for me.
I went to Ed Atsinger, our
CEO, the head of Salem.
I said, look, boss, I'm going to
have to quit in the next year,
because I've got this
thing I want to do.
And he said, don't quit.
Run these shows.
Just make this be another show.
Go do what you do.
Step it up.
It's a nonprofit.
And I went to [INAUDIBLE] who's
the founder of the Federalist
Society.
I share with him the vision.
I went to Dr. Arnn.
And then I went
to Bernie Marcus,
the founder of Home
Depot, and Phil Anschutz,
a really remarkable
Christian philanthropist.
And they both gave me the
seed capital, because they
said, no, build that.
Build it.
So what we're doing
now is building
a two-hour a day
national storytelling
show, on radio, because that's
still where the people are.
And then ultimately one
day it'll be podcasts.
And what we hope to do is build
enough intellectual property,
enough stories about
all kinds of Americans,
that one day we can go to a
Netflix or somebody like it
and say, hey, we've got
hundreds and hundreds
of hours of content.
We've got a whole lot of fans.
The stories have been written.
And we'd like to just film them.
I'd also love-- the
vision would be--
to have a bunch
of the people who
work for me, at one
day in the future,
say, hey, I want to
start my own show.
I want to start my own thing.
And then I will have
done the best service
to my donors, which
is to train up
a new generation of executives,
because this is a business.
And we heard this in the
country special all the time.
Country music is business.
If you don't sell records,
then you don't have a career.
And then if you don't go
tour, you don't have a career.
The left's really good at this.
They take this business
really seriously.
And that's the plan, is to
just go do something big
and have a big cultural impact.
We try not to be on
talk radio stations.
We want to be on
country stations.
classic rock stations.
And then when somebody hears
the story of Henry Ford,
they're going to
go, my goodness,
I did not know that he
got wealthy lowering
the price of cars
and that cars, which
were hereto not available
to even kings 50 years ago,
and then were only
available to the rich,
were now available to everybody.
And we explain
capitalism that way,
that nothing else can lower
the price of something
and make it better and
cheaper than capitalism can,
through competition,
through free enterprise,
and through, in the end,
consumers choosing who wins
and who loses, not by
force, but by choice.
And by the way, this
resonates with people
when I talk to kids in schools
and I talk to them about life
as it is.
I said, you know--
one day I played a
clip of Barack Obama.
And Obama had said
in 2009 what we
need to do is take all
the insurance companies,
get rid of the
profits of each one,
market in each one,
fold them into one
enterprise, and then we'll
be more efficient.
And I went, anybody
here think there's
a problem with
what he just said?
They didn't really flush it out.
I said, now, think
about your own lives.
Think about flat-screen TVs.
And I put a picture up of
the first flat-screen TV.
And the first flat-screen
TV cost, like, $15,000,
and it weighed,
like, 8,000 pounds.
And three rich guys had it.
And it didn't work.
Now, all I did was flash
forward to flat-screen TVs,
how much better they've gotten,
how much lighter they've
gotten, and how much
cheaper they've gotten.
So I said, now, look at
all the companies that
are making flat-screen TVs.
There are a whole
bunch of companies.
Some succeeded.
Some didn't.
Let's look at potato chips.
I took a picture of
a potato chip out.
Look at all those
different potato
chips, all the
different profits,
all the different marketing,
all the different CEOs.
What would the potato
chip aisle look
like if the federal
government made
one potato chip, the
National Potato Chip Company?
Do you think those would
be good potato chips?
Do you think they'd
be cheap potato chips?
What part of your life
doesn't free markets work for?
And by the way, this
is astounding to them,
because I'm not telling
you to be a Republican.
I'm not telling you
to be a Democrat.
I try not to use
the word capitalism,
because it just means
so many bad things.
But when I just talk about
freedom and their own lives
and why they choose one
restaurant and not another
and what would happen if there
was one government restaurant?
Oh, that's right.
It's the commissary,
and you don't eat there.
Crummy food and high prices.
So again, I'm hopeful about
all these things, because we
have God on our side.
We have the right
story on the side.
We have the Constitution
on our side.
We have history on our side.
We've just been really
crummy at this thing
called the [? meaning. ?]
And if we just dared
to play in this space,
we'd take 50% market
share in 10 years,
because we've got 50% of
the country, at least.
And I actually
think we'd get a lot
of these centrist
Democrats, too,
because there's troubles now.
I think that a lot
more people would
be hospitable to our
ideas if they met us
first through story rather
than through a politician.
One last question.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Maybe [INAUDIBLE]
there is not a market for this
and that's why it's done on NPR.
I'm a music fanatic,
and the kind
of music that I'm
fanatical about
is Beethoven and
Brahms and Wagner.
Now, maybe there's
just no market,
and that's why NPR runs it.
The price, the tax that
I pay for listening
to my beautiful music
all day is once an hour,
I have to listen to five
minutes of really increasingly
disgusting propaganda.
And then every night
at 7:00, I have
to listen to an hour of that.
But that's the tax.
Is there a market
for doing packaging
that in another way for
people who love their country?
LEE HABEEB: Well, I
can tell you this.
I grew up listening to opera
because my father was Italian.
And so Puccini
played all the time.
But I would bring my
friends, and they'd
sort of like Puccini, but then
in came Bruce Springsteen.
And it couldn't compete.
And Irving Berlin said this
best, because when he came,
he said, look, I want to make
classical American music.
And I think, in the end,
our classical American music
is Copeland and it's Dylan.
And it just is.
So I would say that classical,
jazz, NPR can afford it
because it's subsidized.
And then they can
say it's educational.
But it's some of the
only places we now
have classical music
left on the dial.
And I love it.
AUDIENCE: It's obsolete.
LEE HABEEB: But
it's almost gone.
And only sort of a few
elite neighborhoods have it.
So it's mostly cities that
play the classical music.
And then the price you pay for
having your classical music is
having to listen to Fresh Air.
And so I'm so sorry,
because that's painful,
to listen to Terry Gross.
And by the way,
if you've noticed,
NPR is just global warming now.
I mean, it is just non-stop
sustainability and LGBTQIA.
I mean, it just never ends.
Even Marketplace,
which is supposed
to be about the economy,
is never about the economy.
So you can't even make it up.
But it is what it is.
NPR is actually a ministry.
It is a ministry.
People are donating.
And that's their church.
And it's a secular ministry, a
secular progressive ministry.
And while we were
trying to do is go,
oh, this will be a ministry.
Our American Stories
will be a pro-rule
of law, pro-American
ministry that
loves free enterprise and God.
And so my feeling
has always been,
as Bernie Marcus told me--
and he's one of my heroes.
He started Home Depot.
He said, it's so much easier to
be a Lowe's than a Home Depot.
The guy who comes out and builds
the market goes out there,
and then Lowe's just
sits around and goes,
hm, let's just copy
Home Depot and take
30% of their market share.
Let's steal some of
their executives.
And let's, you know, poach
some of their managers.
And so in the end, here's
NPR doing something,
and I'm just sitting
there studying it, going,
what did they do right?
Let's do it better.
And let's just sort of
reverse-engineer the stuff
they do and just do it better.
So I'm very hopeful, because
innovators, disruptors,
and entrepreneurs
are just starting
to enter into this space.
And if I can inspire
a few, that'll
be even more important than
making the content itself,
is inspiring others to
innovate in the space.
SPEAKER 2: Thank you.
LEE HABEEB: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]